hello and welcome to a special edition
of spectator TV I'm Katie balls and I'm
joined by Kate Andrews and Fraser Nelson
and we are going to be discussing Jeremy
Hunt's spring budget
to begin uh thank you panelists
um
okay what's traffic to you most uh when
it comes to uh what we've heard today I
thought it was quite interesting that it
was the forecast in terms of the obr
saying which have already started to
dominate the news
yeah so I don't think the most
interesting thing was any announcement
that Jeremy Hunt made it was the
forecast around it so the obr have now
said that they no longer predict a
recession they do expect an economic
contraction this year but a relatively
mild one about 0.2 percent uh and they
think we're going to avoid the technical
definition of recession which is two
consecutive quarters of negative growth
I mean that's really good news and then
if you look at their forecast for growth
in the future over the next four years
they average around two percent now is
that incredible is that you know what we
need post covid no we probably need
something more but it's a lot better
than where we were and this has given
Jeremy Hunt a lot more room to maneuver
so he now has a fiscal Headroom for
borrowing is expected of around 40
billion that figures much higher than
people have estimated he's already spent
about 15 billion of that year on year in
what he's promised today around child
care and and lots of the other policies
that we can get into but the really big
news I think is these forecasts and the
other one I would quickly mention is
inflation I mean this one kind of struck
me and let's hope it's let's hope it's
correct the obr now thinks that
inflation is going to get down to just
below three percent by the end of the
year that's the headline rate of course
um that would suggest that where we are
now above 10 in double digits is going
to fall to something really close to the
bank's Target it is the most optimistic
forecast I've seen on inflation yet and
given where we are now the obr must
think we're looking at a spectacular
fall in the headline rate to get there
by the end of the year so phrase if that
comes to pass for you be cheering on
Rishi sunak for one of his priorities
well that's pretty much what we expected
before Russia became prime minister it
was a little bit better but remember
inflation is falling all over the world
the British Fall is being replicated in
France and Germany and Canada and Israel
so to claim credit for it as this
government is rather misleadingly trying
to do I think isn't something which I
would go along with but this was a
pretty minimalist budget and that we all
expected it's got lots of bad news we
all expected the big corporation tax
increases and have proceeded as planned
the overall tax burden next year will be
the highest ever in British and
peacetime history so these are pretty
significant if you're a conservative
government wanting re-election what then
do you say to the public in election
time that we are the party of low
taxation difficult thing to do but what
jumped out at me most of all was the
welfare reform I think that's our
biggest single problem not just in the
economy but in the country right now
though we've got something like 5.2
million people on out of work benefits a
million more than we had pre-pandemic
now of course during the pandemic lots
of crazy things happened but you would
expect that when the lockdown stop the
recovery can begin and yet the recovery
is coming in without the skills and the
um abilities and the presence of some of
the half a million people a few people
in the living market now than were
expected to be and a million more on
benefits so so I was really looking in
this budget to see what suneck would do
about this I know that he thinks it's a
problem the question is how much room
for maneuver the government's got and
now verbally we heard quite a lot from
Jeremy Hunt he was saying that the
conservatives of the party of work they
believe in them the virtues and this is
sort of typical kind of Tory language
and he said he would be increasing
um conditionality in other words if you
want to receive benefits then he might
make it a little bit harder for you you
might have to show you're doing more of
a work search Etc of course when you
hear these words in the budget the big
question is what does it add up to so
there nowadays we turn to the office for
Budget responsibility which says it's
going to have a negligible effect just
10 000 more people in work now that's a
lot of people but not when you think
about those 5.2 million on benefits so
on the face of what the obr has got to
say it might be too pessimistic but on
the face of what it's got to say right
now there's not much reason for
believing that this problem which means
that one in five people in Birmingham
and Liverpool and Glasgow aren't out of
Road benefits right now but this problem
is going to go away anytime soon and on
that
item group so one is losing benefits one
is uh the people he thinks are retiring
early who need to get off the golf
course and then there's those who are
not taking work because of child care
and the obr is a bit more optimistic
okay when it comes to that child care
pledge in terms of um how many people
that could get back into the workplace
yeah so the opr is more optimistic on
the child care front and the changes
that that's going to meet they estimate
that 75 000 people primarily women may
be able uh to get back into the
workforce but we have to be a little bit
skeptical of these Child Care policies
and the knock-on effects
um so you know we talk about free child
care well of course it's not free it's
fun to buy the taxpayer and when you
create you know free stuff for a certain
group of people it's going to increase
the demand from that group and what is
already a very tight Market I mean
there's just not
um a load of Supply when it comes to
child care they put out an incentive
they haven't their own child Menders
they have and they've changed the ratio
slightly to make it slightly more
liberal but given the fact that the UK
has some of the highest child care costs
in the oecd the hard truth here is that
these subsidies for one group May well
make costs higher for another group and
that might mean that they use it less so
it will be interesting to see if that 75
000 figure if the government can reach
it or if it actually ends up being
offset with other people who feel like
they actually can't access child care as
much the pension stuff is interesting
too and I think that the policy is right
the increase of the pension annual
allowance abolishing the lifetime
allowance I think these are sensible
things for Jeremy Hunt to do but the
real difficulty has when it comes to
older workers is that so many of those
people especially during the covid years
will have realized that they're quite
comfortable where they are perhaps
they're planning to earn a bit more
money but they now realize that they can
live without it and a lot of those
people aren't going to want to return to
the grind and so whilst these incentives
I think might be meaningful for some
people the idea that you can
fundamentally shift that perspective to
get 55 60 year olds who are really happy
with their new lifestyle back into work
requires a mindset change as well and
it's not one that I think the state
ultimately ultimately is going to be
best place to deliver Fraser you've kept
quite a close eye on Jonathan Ashworth
and the labor party and what he's been
saying on the ads of work
um who are you more impressed by Mel's
stride obviously Jeremy Hunt speaking
today but here's the work and pension
secretary and all Jonathan Ashworth in
terms of what both parties are talking
about I think the labor party right now
has got two very impressive front
Ventures we're treating the health
charity Health secretary and Jonas were
Shadow working pensions I think he is
now using the language which the Tories
were using in opposition saying look at
this waste of human lives is worth money
and not enough is being done now of
course I think he's quite sincere there
whether the rest how much of the rest of
his party is on board with him is
another question
um but I do think the Tories are just
going way too way too slowly on this I
mean an extra 10 000 is just negligible
really but if you have a look at the obr
figures they're the the real boost of
the workforce isn't going to come from
the back to work mums about 75 000 nor
is a good income from people coming off
welfare 10 000 is going to come from
immigrants 160
000. now to me this was the really big
thing looking at the obr's forecast is
now expecting the post-brexit regime not
to be letting in net migration of 205
000 as it thought only a few months ago
in November it now thinks it's going to
be 245
000. so over the next five years it's
going to expect about 1.6 million people
to arrive up from 1.3 now this is this
has big implications for example in 2020
27 the obr says it expects growth of
about two percent a quarter of which is
going to come simply from increased net
migration so it seems here as if the
conservatives are now doing what they
accused labor of doing in opposition
relying on immigrants to get the job
done as it were to come home and do the
most of the economic work while not
really making much inroads into a number
of British people on benefits who we can
help back into work it has been doing
something with disability benefits these
are all good and they're welcome versus
400 million to look at mental health for
example but to me perhaps the single
most shocking part of the obr report is
looking at what it expects for mental
health and mental health problem is one
which the conservatives did not expect
if you look at the number of claims now
for mental health for disability
allowance they're running it broadly
speaking more than double they were
pre-pandemic and the obr thinks that um
by 2027
12 of the workforce in this country is
going to be on some kind of health
related benefit that's up from eight
percent pre-pandemic so it sees the
overall problem of a welfare system
which is just not really helping people
with mental health issues it's basically
ensnaring them in welfare it's not
getting them back to work it sees this
problem being very bad now but getting a
lot worse now I think this is something
which neither political party has really
started to talk about it's complicated
and there there are some mental health
issues where people spoke a lot on the
pandemic about how lockdowns would
exacerbate mental health I'm not quite
sure anybody expected the sheer volume
of mental health and benefit claims to
be as high as it was now and the obr now
says it can it expects us to be a
significant and sustained Trend in the
British economy we expect this to go on
for years way after the election expect
that because nobody has come up with any
kind of solution to recognize let alone
fix this problem and Kate moving back to
tax
um ultimately Fraser's spoken about how
there's definitely some disappointment
despite I think the fact the treasury
were pretty clear in advance because
they knew it'd be such a rat that the
corporation tax uplift is going ahead
um something rich you see like has
personally backed for some time so not
such a surprise but he had tried to
soften it didn't he he did he has
brought in a system of full expensing
which should be fair a lot of free
marketeers have been calling for again
quite sensible policy he's trying to
sell it as a 9 billion pound corporation
tax cut I'm not sure that people are
going to buy that aspect of it that he
somehow brought in this massive cut when
he's actually hiking the rate for the
largest businesses
um but to expand tax out a little bit
Katie for me this budget told us a lot
about how Jeremy Hunt and Rishi sunak
really see their role in and and the
size of the state because for months now
we've had Sue Knack and Hunt talking
about how how you know their real
commitment is to fiscal responsibility
to getting the public finances back in
order that has been the narrative since
the mini budget blow up under Liz
troughs and you still see that narrative
in today's budget but what's so telling
is that whilst on the one hand they
really want to say like we're The
Prudent ones they are now overseeing a
massive state so not only do you have
the tax burden near a post-war high as
Fraser mentioned the obr estimates that
the ratio of public spending to GDP now
is going to settle at around 43.5
percent which is the highest sustained
level since the 1970s
um you know this is not a small state
government and whilst there's a lot of
talk about responsibility they are just
about sustaining the management of an
absolutely massive State and one that
they're contributing to with you know
additional packages and all the rest of
it these are not people who are
interested in cutting the size of
government at least not yet now maybe
they're waiting to do that in another
budget but it's straight strikes me that
this idea that the Tories are in any way
going to be small state conservatives is
just so long gone now I don't know if
you're supposed to do okay but this this
new one million pound prize the
government's giving to somebody to an
award to come up with some new AI
Innovation and it's strange this is a
very sort of interventionist big States
conservatism sort of thing that it's the
government's job to encourage scientists
and innovators to do what they want and
it's the government's rule to offer a
million pounds of taxpayers money to
people who come up now the thing is in a
competitive free market if you come up
with a fantastic new idea you sell it to
a company who can monetize it pretty
quickly but it's funny that almost the
reaction of these guys now is that it's
the government's rule to Foster
Innovation to to try to incubate the
scientific research Etc and you know
it's hardly the biggest Financial
measurement in this budget but still a
sign of where they are
um mentally but they start to think
they're in charge of the whole country
not just the Public Services
and just finally Fraser and
we're talking about the budget it's
a good news today when it comes to the
economy or could that be taking place
somewhere else
you're referring Publications acrylic
Suites and the wobbles and that are
happening right now now it's certainly
the case that
um that when Global interest rates are
even a little bit higher we're talking
three or four percent you start to see
things wobbling that would never wobble
before so and I think in Kate's cover
piece she rather brilliantly draws a
line and between the pension crisis
which pretty much deposed less trusts a
few months ago and the Californian
Russians which led to the collapse of
svb bank over there and um what's
happening now with credit Suites because
there is so there's a phrase in finance
that you keep raising rates until
something breaks and when you do raise
eventually you find how many businesses
we're basically betting on rates never
going up like these Museum Californians
were all their Investments and bonds the
value of which goes down when rates go
up and it just didn't hedge against an
era where rates would go significantly
higher they topple over so we're now
seeing how much of our financial
architecture was always based on this
massive bet that rates would never go up
um and we could be in for some point now
I don't think by the way the Credit
Suisse will follow it's got a very
different business model there wasn't a
run in the bank like there was with The
Californians but I do think that we're
in an era now where there's going to be
more unpleasant surprises there was note
from Capital economics this morning
saying that these one-off things were
happening rather a lot now the pension
crisis supposed to be a one-off VM the
collapse of the regional banks in
America at one off and now the wobbles
of Credit Suisse are one-off were always
told one of isolated events sooner or
later
um as K argues in her piece you'll see a
pattern and we will wonder what's next
thank you Fraser thank you Kate and
thank you for watching
[Music]